one of the great things and businesses
you don't know if you don't ask right
and so one of the reasons I love Twitter
and social media and specifically
Twitter is I see the comments more even
more than on Instagram and sometimes
jump in and surprise and delight you are
witnessing a surprise and delight right
now what's the number corstel you better
pick up hello hey crystal it's Gary me
Oh Gary Vaynerchuk hi how are you I'm
looking great thank you think you think
you don't so much for calling me I have
been on tense and you tweeted me
yesterday I love it I love living I love
living on 10 and anything I can do to
get people to live on 10 is exactly
right I like that so what can I help you
with okay I have two two things one I'm
gonna ask on the app of me
so I'm Justin I want to be I want to say
a marriage counselor I'm not sure I'm
not sure it's even that's the right word
because I don't want to be boxed into
like an office you know a clinic or what
happens you I see my future writing book
doing speaking engagements conferences
things like that just arms the point or
information and tools so that that you
know people can have better marriages
but I am finding that every time I
mentioned that let's go you know what
you want to do to like tell people this
their instant book response it is you
know hiding to do that you're not
married my parents are the board as if I
was eight of them seven eight I'm not
married I can't I can answer your
question right away we're gonna build it
amis yeah we're gonna build an amazing
case study together I'm gonna give you
I'm gonna give you three names and then
you're gonna cruise into the sunset of
success which is let's figure out the
three most successful coaches in the
history of
that everybody knows of that didn't play
that sport
Bill Belichick even though I hate him
with all my guts did not play football
he grew up in the football game right
his dad and what was a coach shouldn't
have you but Bill Belichick did not play
football and he will probably
unfortunately go down as the greatest or
if not one of the greatest head coaches
of all time you don't have to be listen
I think you have to be people have to be
thoughtful
I hate 22 year old life coaches that
haven't lived life but if they if they
speak about here's my life experiences
and and why you you can eliminate though
very quickly the art when somebody says
to you but how are you you can't do let
me first of all a couple other questions
are your friends and your circle telling
you you can't do that or customers that
you're trying to do that with telling
you that they don't want to go with you
because you're not married know this
this is more acquaintance Azhar people
you know that I run into yeah so listen
that's a mistake
listen that's a mistake like you can't
listen to acquaintances or opinions
don't matter okay you kid with some
stone half you can every how do you have
I'm sorry no go ahead I'm sorry I'm
getting excited
you should talk up basically like I
wanna because I follow you and I was
following you for a couple years now and
I do agree what you have to say about
education I do think people are gonna
start moving from you know going to
school is the favorite kids to school to
find you I've got your answer
I've got your answer and a lot of people
get up you know of course I know I know
exactly where you're going so if you're
not gonna get the PhD there's only a few
ways to justify and gives confidence to
the end market what what why they would
jump with you it's crazy to me that so
many people I was watching 60 minutes
last night in the background as I was
working and the way that Oprah was
justifying the person was he has a PhD
in this and a master's in that even 60
minutes use those pieces of paper to
create a far authority in our society
pieces of paper from businesses and
that's what colleges are
has been the authority the only other
people that get Authority are the people
that have gone out and done it and have
people co-signing them right makes sense
so the way your and this is why I love
working for free when you don't have a
piece of paper right one of the reasons
I love working for free is working for
free for somebody who is that person in
society whether they got a piece of
paper or their Puff Daddy and they just
did it becomes the equity that you trade
under once you become great at something
right and Andy who's sitting here right
now how every single famous person I see
gives him a lot of street cred right
away not because he got a [ __ ] degree
for personal branding and marketing for
Virginia Tech what the Greek you get not
because of his [ __ ] [ __ ]
political science degree from Virginia
Tech but because he went and worked
underneath me and I went out and did it
and I always give him love and good
vibes the end it's not babiness degree
from the USC School of [ __ ] film or
NYU you know so what you need to do it
what you need to do is one of two moves
if you're not gonna go get a PhD and
have everybody comfortable with it you
need they're gonna need to go work for
somebody that is the authority and ask
all thousands of people that are
authorities and work for them or okay
you need to give your services for free
to five couples crush it for them and
use their word-of-mouth and endorsements
and as your leverage point the end
there's three ways to win the game one
the traditional piece of paper route to
work for free for somebody and siphon
off their equity once you deliver for
them or three eat [ __ ] and do it
yourself in the beginning and let the
testimonials of the early people give it
for you I'm on three I recommend often
to ninety-nine percent of the world
plays one
okay awesome aqua waffle that was some
good [ __ ] actually yeah that was done
out of that it's very rare when I get to
the real point like that's the [ __ ]
point those are the three pillars of
trying to gain market acceptance the
three pillars of market acceptance I
love it I love it and then so I'm not
wait to like message you in like a year
or three to five years and tell you
where I'm at me too
I live for that [ __ ] my whole [ __ ]
being is right now is based on that [ __ ]
it will be great copy yeah that is gonna
be great content okay real quick cause I
gotta run to my next thing what's the
other you had another thing yeah so I
work for a company here in Lancaster
Pennsylvania were a wholesaler for
memory cards and I I do work here and I
enjoy what I do for the team and like
they just bring some of the values to me
in my life but I really want to be like
a mess level employee here and I want up
them with their social media but I just
don't know how to do it is what we're
doing is not a proprietary you build a
brand you build a reputation when you
when you're not proprietary like most
things in the world you build a brand a
bottled water is not proprietary like
they say it is but it's not like like
you know most things are non proprietary
okay a sneakers not I mean like you know
the the innovation and sneakers are is
you know evolved but they're I mean a
t-shirt let's go there tee shirts aren't
proprietary but like you know for a
while there Ambercrombie and Fitch for a
while they're american apparel for a
while there for now supreme like build
up when you when you don't have any
proprietary value you have to build a
brand okay and how do i start that for
them you make content for the people
that are buying the product so you're in
the b2b business I assume right yeah I
got it b2b and b2c right
yeah so you make content for the b2b
world and you make content for the b2c
world you make a funny video for
Instagram and target people that are
most likely to buy memory cards or
employees of organs I would here's what
I always do when you want to do it for a
company I look at where the money's
coming from and I make content for those
people meaning I would look at where
sales are being generated and then I
would make content for that psycho and
demographic so if your biggest cuff
client is staples I would make content
for the staples buyer if you're if
you're if you're selling a ton on Amazon
I would look at the data and be like why
is everybody from Wisconsin buying our
product let's make some Wisconsin based
shirt I reverse engineer the actual
people that are buying okay and try to
figure out how to bring them value in
utility or entertainment in my creative
which then leads to you know ROI I'm
both on both utility and escapism
entertainment right people watch daily
be in my clips both for information but
a lot of people don't even realize a lot
of people are watching just for an
entertainment they just want to see what
the trials and tribulation of babban
versus d-roc are today you might be
robbed to have it that's right see this
was just a very this was a very meta
moment for me right like a lot of people
like I'm doing both more utility than
entertainment but clearly both and I
think that you know you watch Star Wars
for a reason and you watch a how-to
video - you know for a memory card for a
reason and both work those are the two
pillars that you trade on
okay um and then just to accident so I
find that my my bosses they're kind of
scared that someone's gonna like take
our idea because not Society proprietary
and run with it and I've been watching
you you know you're really you're really
preach on like listen people even if
they know how to do it they're not going
to do how many how many how many how
many employees work in the company
I need like things like it's not a lot
of love right and you and do you
understand the prep prep proprietary
nature of what you guys do like if you
left tomorrow would you be able to if
you had enough money do it as well yes
absolutely and then your and then your
then your bosses are not very smart and
this is what I'm saying that in a tough
way and I don't really mean it but this
is what makes me laugh at people the
reason I'm a good the reason I'm a good
guy and give everything away is there
are no secrets right like what's the why
wouldn't why wouldn't it be scary for
you to go and work for a competitor and
bring back I mean like that they're
old-school in their thinking they
haven't calibrated the extreme nature of
the internet too many people trying to
hold on to a secret that doesn't exist
and so what that does it makes them
religious about defense when it's never
been more important to go on the offense
okay but that's a tough play because
like I don't think you walking into the
room is gonna convince them do you know
what I mean right I don't think they'll
either but maybe though maybe they'll
watch this full clip whenever I put it
up in full in a month and maybe that
will get them going because they're not
sitting on anything yes this whole thing
is this whole videos going out you're
famous now
so listen that's just the way it is most
companies when they hit a level where
they're happy they try to go on defense
when they think they're sitting on a
secret but they're not sitting on as big
of a secret as they think okay alright
the intermedia would be smaller not
bigger if I held on to all these good
ideas
their chair Sunday weekend all right
this was a lot of fun and see what
happens when you ask on the Internet
[ __ ] happens yes oh my gosh I love you
Gary thank you so much for taking the
time I'm so so grateful please you know
what I know you did
no worries take care of a bye bye keep
on tweeting
[Music]